at least 15 wounded during an exchange
of gunfire at a funeral
uh for chicago gun violence victims jeez
dude there was over
the perfect example i think they said
over 80 casings the police
officer said 80 casings so it was a gun
battle like they were
i mean it wasn't just like a few shots
80 uh bullet casings were found on the
scene
that's crazy that's not just that's
chicago
you're right that's chicago it's a war
zone this is this is
one instance this story happened today
the day
trump announced operation legend yep and
this story perfectly exemplifies
exactly why donald trump is doing it it
was a funeral for a victim of gun
violence
and gun violence broke out come on man
come on yep reminds me that southwest
episode
come on people now come on here's what
we saw yesterday from the washington
post
2020 is shattering gun violence records
we must act
it's a cool photo of a bunch of guns
well i'm sure they're gonna they're
gonna try to connect it to the amount of
gun sales that have gone through the
roof also
but this those aren't the guns that are
causing this violence
i mean i i don't i didn't read through
this article this is the first time i've
seen it this is a photo of guns from
2011.
of course it is yeah they pulled a stock
photo of guns and they're like guns bad
well look i i don't i don't know what
he's saying his article and quite
honestly that's not the point
i'm i'm showing this this article
because
the washington post just yesterday
published an op-ed saying
we must act and what happens the next
day donald trump comes out and says
it's time to act and then what does the
anti-trump people
he's actually acting wait what
this is not what you wanted this is
another really good example of
one of i think the problems we face in
this country
trump will see something in the news
yeah he'll respond to it
and then they'll reverse their position
so like the news will say something like
we've got a serious crime problem
throughout this nation and something
needs to be done about it where is the
president yeah then trump will come out
the next day and be like
the the violence across this country is
terrible everybody agrees we're going to
do something about it
trump is sending in police what does he
think he is a dictator uh
it happened i i kid you not i i i i i
know
the media will report something it's
it's worse than that they'll say
something like
the sky is blue and trump will go i i
did you hear this on the news the other
day the sky is apparently blue it's
incredible
and then they'll report trump is so dumb
this guy is black where did he get this
idea
and then they'll be like fact check
false trump stupid
like i kid you not there are things
reported in the news that i hear trump
repeat and then all of a sudden
the news is the other direction now yes
tim yes let the pill
just go into your veins break open and
oh but dude i work for these companies
yeah i worked for them
i've been your friend as and and we've
had many conversations of what you've
been through
over these past you know let me let me
tell you of knowing you one of my
favorite stories
was when uh and we've been i think we
mentioned this before when ghost in the
shell the movie came out with scarlett
johansson right
right and i'm in a meeting and they're
like can you believe that they're like
hiring a white actress to play
you know uh the the major in in this
film that's like
motoko kasanagi i think is the name of
the character and the anime and i was
like
actually i'm i'm a fan and i think that
that actually makes sense like
the theme of the show is like you can
change bodies right i thought they would
have loved this
because it's transhumanism so like in
this universe of ghost in the shell
theoretically
you could be like born a dude and then
transfer into a prosthetic female body
instead they're like no it racism and
i'm like but i'm telling you
i know this show and they're like no
racism
and i'm like okay i don't know what i'm
doing here dude
yeah they weren't interested in the
truth they were interested in some kind
of narrative
the worst thing about it is they there
are people who are trapped in this world
of fake news
that's true so trump is sending out
police okay
good i think most people are thinking
good
awesome i'm so happy that this is
actually in this violence
legend operation legend just to
let everyone know legend is the name of
a four-year-old boy that was killed
from a stray bullet from a gunfight
in kansas city and this is this is a
terrible shame no one's talking about
this
this little little child that just got
killed a four-year-old and that's
that's that's why there are a lot of
activists that you know you know what
man
bevel and beaty yeah amazing she's
amazing because she it's it's it's not
that
i agree with her politics it's that
people have to be brave to stand up for
these things
absolutely when the media props you up
and you demand it see the table
respect yeah exactly you know i watched
i watched trump's speech about this
and you know that i was telling you
about this earlier i was i was wondering
if they were going to talk about who was
doing the violence
not one time did they talk about it
there was no
you know trying to counter with
statistics of like you know black on
black crime and whatever and it's like
because that's not that's not what's
important that what's important are
people are actually dying
little children are getting killed all
across this country
and people are ignoring that fact
because it's
why actually i i still don't understand
why they're ignoring it
i want to make sure i clarify i don't
know if i misspoke but the idea is
then the media will say black lives
matter and they'll pull up all these
left-wing activists and then someone
like beverly has to be like
you know i have a you know a voice that
needs to be heard right and they have to
fight
really hard and the media barely gives
them attention so
so let's talk about chicago man yeah
let's think about
fbi dea and law enforcement coming down
to chicago what 200
no one's going to notice let's be real
no one's going to notice and that's
and that's kind of sad kind of good
i growing up in chicago i i mentioned
this earlier on one of my other
segments if i was leaving my house and i
saw these uh
cbp dudes in camo with rifles
on the street corner you know what i
would do i'd like to text a friend and
be like yo what's up with these dudes
yeah they're here because it's like some
law enforcement think of that crazy
right that's it
and then keep walking yes yep it's funny
because
i i realized one thing the left seems to
think
that libertarians what be it left wing
or right wing i mean like you know just
basically freedom loving people yeah are
supposed to believe that law enforcement
existing in your presence is a violation
of your rights
yeah no no no no listen when the camo
dudes kick my door in
and then say or i got one when the
government arrests me for legally
protecting my home in the face of a
large group of people who are breaking
onto my private
property that's oppression from a a
secret police state or something
when a bunch of dudes are standing on a
corner and they are armed and they're
like we're cops and you're like
okay and they say have a good day sir
thank you your rights have not been
violated right the existence of law
enforcement is not a violation of your
rights or to get more specific with it
when those same officers are inside a
barricaded court a federal courthouse
and you start lobbing fireworks at them
grade mortar shells at the the office
and they see you
and follow you and then detain you know
this is for questioning
dude this reminds me i mean you kind of
asked for it
have you seen that meme where it's a
it's a woman and she's wearing a sweater
that says like feminist
and she's shoveling feces over a wall
yeah that says the internet
yeah and and the human waste is opinions
and she's like grinning and doing it in
the next panels they throw it back and
she goes help misogyny
that's like literally what it is yeah
it's true you don't you show up to a
federal courthouse
and you start setting fires and
attacking and breaking the barricades
and then the cops come out and they're
like
leave and you go help help i'm being
repressed nah man look that's what we're
seeing
the objects they're just trying to
manipulate the optics and show everyone
i i i'm so annoyed with the the few
friends of mine that are like how dare
you
like you cherish property over peaceful
protesters and i'm like
are you are you talking to me
are you not paying attention unless
you're on the ground
you don't know and it's like i watch i
watch
their videos right from them from them
posting like look at this and it's them
attacking and breaking down the walls of
the courthouse while they cheer
while they're cheering like like we
broke into the courthouse it's not a
secret
that's wait that's why they're coming
after you why what
it doesn't make sense it's tribalism
dude
there's this guy who messaged you know
when i posted about the the pawn shop
being burned down
right this guy came out immediately it's
a guy i know from my neighborhood
and he was like you don't even care
about police brutality man all you do is
just right-wing griff blah blah blah
and i responded with like i was like he
said like you never talk about place
brutality and i was like i'm
i can't i've dedicated countless hours
yeah calling out absolutely
with like george floyd like we and then
he was like
no all you ever do is talk about you
know the left blah blah
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
people started posting my videos because
i'm not going to go
i don't know i do i do three hours of
content per day
four hours so there's a there's a whole
bunch of videos being posted
where i'm and i'm like i wonder what i
did say about this and i click it and
it's me going like this is disgusting
what this officer did
he deserves prison and i'm like why is
this guy yelling at me yeah
well he doesn't watch your videos
exactly they don't exactly but but
i think it's also like we're talking
about the rage filter yep the rage
they're like anything trump does must be
bad they don't think about
what's actually happening right and then
once they find your stance
and if it's not their stance all stances
that they
everything that they believe you now
believe the exact opposite
of all of them because you're now evil
and evil things believe the exact
opposite of what they believe so
therefore
everything i believe is the opposite of
you this is who i hate you now this is
what how i've talked about
binary bugs bunnying people right where
you get them to assert the opposite
stance like make a left-wing person take
a right-wing position
and you can so a conservative wouldn't
do this
if if you post something like you know
all cops are bad
and a conservative and this is a
tendency not an absolute okay
and they respond saying like you're so
dumb that's ridiculous of course not
every cop is bad you're blinded by
propaganda
and you respond with something like you
know uh
actually i think cops are good of course
there are good cops it's you who think
this they'd be like wait what i agree
with you what are you talking about
right but these these these lefty tribal
people that often
in trying to engage in my content have
no real opinions
they're just angry rage-filled
tribalists so when they say
when the dude started attacking me this
is really really funny he started saying
things like
you know i don't care you clearly don't
care about police brutality what
three videos get posted and he's still
trying to push this and then i finally
said what happened to you bro
someone just posted a 14 minute rant by
me where the first thing i say is like
wow this is insane this video is
discussing i think we can all agree this
guy who did wrong yeah
and then finally he goes yeah well you
know what you're still a right-wing
grifter
and then i went to respond he deleted
the whole thread
because it was his comment so he deleted
it and just like shut it down
that's what i was talking about uh
yesterday with uh that interview
that eric july was doing and he was just
he was trying to he was like
hit me up let's talk about it and
someone someone on the far left hit him
up was like trying to argue with him
yeah and he he was like what about this
and this and this
go ahead i'll wait and he just you know
minutes
turned into a while longer and it was
just like all right
listen i got nothing i'm going to have
to concede this click yeah that's great
you know but it kind of makes me feel
like we've mentioned this before how
there's like different factions
is it the left versus the right is it
sjw versus nsw nationals versus
globalist
yeah i think it's that the internet is
cr has been filtering
people between critical thinkers and
mindless rage monsters
so so critical thinkers have political
opinions across the spectrum that's true
like eric weinstein is a progressive
and he sits down with ben shapiro and
they literally argue economic policy
but they agree on freedom and liberty
and you know
civil rights and all that stuff yeah but
then you take one of these like rage
monsters
they won't even do the interviews or
they just try and straw man
and argue semantics wait you used which
word
that word doesn't believe what you know
i don't believe that means what you
think it means therefore the argument
you've lost i win
oh good i get to argue about something
else now cause i was running on fumes
yeah it's like semantic arguments is the
best i've seen
from from the left and progressives yeah
so so we're working on this this card
game
you know uh the the cancel culture and
we started thinking about like prominent
left-wing people that we could satirize
in the game
and it's really difficult that's a good
point who is the
like prominent leader of course there
are a lot of people we can name
okay but because they don't have solid
opinions
it's hard to represent what they
actually do yeah that's a good point so
like when we say something like we're
gonna make
we're gonna make a satire of jordan
peterson peter jordanson
we know so much about his positions his
principles it's really easy to satirize
him making him do something antithetical
to his existence or like
like like shoot shoot lobsters lobster
or like turning people into lobsters or
like fighting lobsters but
it's that's that's that is very simple
but it's also just like
making him the more a more exaggerated
version like he cleans your room yeah
things like that
when it comes to the left it's like
they're just mindless
three like there's very few people to
actually pull up that represent the far
left that have cohesive arguments
there's there are people though we do
have i'm looking at chat and i just got
to give a shout out to chat
they've got some they've got they've
labeled some some a few people that are
pretty solid no i know i know definitely
like definitely i'm looking at them like
yep yep
that's awesome i don't want to say the
name of something but somebody posted it
let's just say um they're we're going to
talk about that i'm going to write that
down for later though
nice job thank you there are high
profile left and people we're going to
satirize yeah yeah for sure
but making fun of them is like
it's different it's different yeah
because like their opinions
bounce ezra klein's a really good
example there was a
someone posted a a forum of like how to
be ezra klein he's the founder of box
one of the founders
and they were like basically he's a
sophist whenever an issue pops up that
is that is
negatively impacting the left he'll be
like actually the thing we need to do
so a good example is when it came to
ruth bader ginsburg he goes
actually lifetime appointments are are
absolutely necessary to the vital
and then when it you know to the vital
body politic and here's why there is a
thread
and then someone else put another one up
where it was like when it came to a
retirement or something or when it came
to a conservative who was like i'm not
going to retire he's like actually we
really do need to set like a time limit
like it's it's there's there's no
opinion like i don't know what the guy
believes right
so basically can we make it so that
every single
one of these these characters is just a
flip-flopper
it's it's difficult to make fun of if
the left is literally just like i'll
believe whatever i'm told to believe
because there there's also high-profile
feminists i know where they'll tweet
something and then a minute later be
like i didn't realize that was offensive
my opinion is now different
and i'm like okay like i don't know
whatever man
or the people that just have no opinions
at all
we're definitely gonna make fun of uh
you know like trumpsters and
enlightened centrists so like
everybody's gonna get roasted and sorry
a certain someone that says they just
want bread they just want bread
give let them have bread let them help
yeah it'll be fun
cortex antoinette thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you